how long do you guys are in a talking
phase with a chick until you ask her to
be your girlfriend I don't really set a
time limit on it it's just whenever
she's ready she'll kind of Hint it it
could take 3 weeks it could take 2
months 3 months usually after before 3
months if she actually likes you she'll
give you the little little hint but uh
yeah you don't set exact times on like
I'm not I'm not setting the time and
like right in my notebook I'm going to
ask her to be my girlfriend on this date
it's kind of just whenever she brings it
up a few days after that then you so you
let her take the initiation
no no I take the initiation she'll bring
it up we'll have a little talk the
you'll take the clues like yeah and then
a few days I'm like by the way congrats
you're my girlfriend